uh welcome to session 13 of classic
metal class it's me greg sadler and my
co-host scott tarrouli a professor of
guitar at berkeley school of music and a
gigging musician somebody who's done a
lot of studio work both of us are
metal heads from childhood and we've
talked a lot about
things and this this this particular
session is going to focus a lot on the
70s even go back into the 60s a bit
pre-medal and we're going to talk about
some things
in the 80s but not
not too much because the the dividing
point for us the dividing line is going
to be the advent of mtv so what are we
talking about in this session
something that we've been
thinking about and started to do a lot
of research on recently which is how did
bands actually
get on the air
in terms of television and other you
know video venues
um or or media prior to mtv because you
know there's this sense that i think a
lot of
people have i've actually seen people
saying oh there weren't any music videos
before mtv and that's clearly false not
just factually but it couldn't ex it
couldn't happen because you had to have
music videos in order to pitch a station
that would be all music videos so where
did this come from and you know if you
if you do a lot of research on metal
using resources like youtube
you wind up seeing
uh lots and lots of videos and you say
well where do these actually come from
uh prior to to this so that's that's
what we're going to be talking about and
it's interesting the more that you
research things in music history there's
always you know fascinating backstories
things turn out to be way more
complicated than the initial picture
that you have going in so it's kind of a
good
uh
thing to keep in mind with any sort of
research right and actually every one of
us here in the session today is a a
researcher um
so all of you can can relate to that so
um
this session is is focused on just you
could say like the
it goes all the way back to the 50s into
the 70s when things are really taking
off
and
it's going to be more of a music history
session i think that you know maybe in
the conversation we'll actually engage
in some philosophy stuff um we've got a
lot of philosophers here in this session
and we're not we're not so much
interested in just like dispelling myths
and stereotypes we're more interested in
adding a richer picture
uh history not quite going back to the
you know otto von ranka you know his
things as they truly were but at least a
a better story a richer story
and i gotta say too one other thing
before i i shut up and let scott talk a
little bit um the research that we're
able to do in the present
is really enabled by the fact that we
have the internet as this massive
archive that all these people have been
uploading stuff to over the last 20 30
years
and
that really is a game changer you know i
couldn't have found out the things that
we're going to talk about or that
scott's going to talk about
without um
doing a lot of you know looking things
up on on websites or
on especially in youtube you know for
the videos
so it's it's kind of incredible that
we're able to do this discussion in the
first place um what do you want to add
you know sort of preliminary stuff scott
um well i i think
you and i initially had had this uh
notion about um well we this started
with okay well mtv and vh1 come out
right and then we said well wait a
minute
but there was clearly this stuff
beforehand and i think you and i brought
up like the beatles having movies
or solid gold or top of the pops yeah
and you know this was pre
mtv and then i said well remember this
corny video like uh was it benny
margolis one uh
uh into the night and that was like
1977.
and
i think although you and i grew up
seeing music on tv and one like whether
it be a late night show
um there was that visual aspect
it was important but it's kind of like i
feel like maybe at least i took it for
granted that it started with mtv
yeah
and
yeah it's like mtv made everything
happen but it really was more of a
catalyst than a
a a cause right
uh meaning that that things had to
already be there to precipitate out and
yeah there were lots and lots of music
shows i mean
i don't want to get into you know
talking about like the lawrence welk
show or stuff like that but i remember
you know people watching it
and and enjoying it um so you know
where was the space for for for metal
that's the question that we're going to
ask and there's some key topics and
questions
that connect with some of the things
we've talked about in other sessions
like the the music itself the records
the concerts the tours the magazines
these are all part of what we can call a
sociological space of heavy metal that
people like donna weinstein have have
explored in their books
um and so we're going to ask about like
well what kind of music videos were
being produced and aired before
mtv
and why were they making them what was
the whole point of having a music video
and then how did people actually see
these you know um
in some places it was easier than others
australia turns out to be incredibly
important for reasons that we'll talk
about and then how do they connect up
with like other things like tv shows and
appearances by heavy metal bands one of
the things that we didn't really get
time to research was like appearances of
bands
on talk shows
but there were a lot of those as well
that we could we could have gone into so
i think we can i mean i might have yeah
yeah some of that
well there's there's so many i mean
you know one of the bands that we're
going to talk about quite a bit is kiss
and kiss were just amazing in marketing
themselves you know either we were
joking about this beforehand lunch boxes
you know we had kiss kiss paraphernalia
when we were kids um that was one band
that really knew how to make money on
getting their brand out there so let's
jump into the backstory um you know we
know that there are plenty of musical
performances within films and even tv
shows one of my favorite uh tv shows
is peter gunn and one of the cool things
about it is it has some really really
good musical performances as part of the
short like 24-minute show
um including by lola albright who is his
girlfriend in the show she did 38 jazz
performances
and she was she was a singer before she
actually started acting on the show
in 1956 tony bennett's record label
filmed him walking through london's hyde
park and they set the footage to his hit
version of stranger in paradise
so
this got distributed and this is this is
actually something that that was a key
idea or a key trick
you would create a music video not to
get like all the kids you know into your
stuff and you know make yourself big on
mtv because it didn't exist you would
create it so you didn't have to show up
because
if you were in demand and this is what
led to the beatles doing it a little bit
later if you're in demand
you could um just say well just watch
this this video it's just as good as me
being there
you know and so tony bennett did that
and it got distributed to uh tv stations
and then they would air it
and american band style stand played it
too so that was kind of important back
then
um so you know way way before metal
people are doing this
uh the beatles mark mark brought this up
that i've heard people argue the beatles
created the first music videos um
not exactly but they they upped the game
in part
because they began producing these
videos it for the same reason so they
didn't have to show up because
you you just can't be everywhere at once
and that started to lead to other bands
doing it too
so it really caught on but there's
another thing that i think is really
kind of kind of cool
there were um video jukeboxes
back in the 1950s the late 50s so there
were there were two companies one was
italian um and they developed the
cinebox
and then there was the scopatone that
came out in france and the scopatone
made it over here to the united states
and a lot of artists kind of felt
ambivalent they didn't want to put their
stuff into these video
things
but nancy sinatra did and you can
actually if you just go online you can
find
her um these boots are made for walk-in
in
a video that is designed specifically to
be played on scopatone so i guess the
way that it worked is you'd go and you
know put your quarters in or whatever it
was and you'd i mean with a regular
jukebox you'd put it on and walk away so
that you could uh go dance or you know
listen to the music or sit at the bar i
guess with this you had to like look at
it
so
yeah it's kind of an interesting idea
and again way way before metal
um there were a couple other things that
i think are important
in this history
um in the 19 in 1970 so like you know a
long long time before we actually
started paying attention to music there
was this show now explosion and it ran
on atlanta's independent channel 17 and
it was a weekend program so it ran for
28 hours and the conception was
that um it would be like you'd have a
couple djs and they would just like keep
plugging away at it and then like hit
sack or something like that and come
back and chit chat so this is like
pre-mtv
um you know sort of like the mtv format
before mtv
and they did a lot of cool things one
was they would take these uh
official promotional and the word that
they use is clips
instead of you know videos they called
them all clips
and then there were also a whole bunch
of unauthorized videos there was an art
scene in atlanta that had you know like
film students and so they would do the
sort of thing that people do on youtube
now
which is you take a track and then you
put your own artwork to it you put your
own stuff to it right which is totally
unauthorized you know the band
might be happy with it might not be
happy with it and so they did it and
then it got syndicated to a bunch of
other locations charlotte sacramento
boston los angeles uh new york san
francisco but it but it folded so it's
one of those things and scott you can
point out all sorts of examples of this
where it's time just hadn't come you
know there weren't there wasn't what
needed to be in place
you know you think about so many musical
movements and um
technology
that uh
you know it's it's now you know
old hat but but at the time it just
people weren't ready for it and uh it
didn't stick i mean are there other
examples that you can think of left hand
of things like that
um
well i mean
we see it big time now i mean it's
interesting that you point out that this
happened before right yeah but
like so let's say you look up a tune and
i think i said this to you like oh is it
whatever uh
uh a nudo tune or something but some fan
would take it and so now the problem is
like i'll have students say stuff and
they'll go that's not the video that's
just somebody
that put a bunch of they made their own
video out of it yeah um
and so it's it's kind of interesting
that this is this started way before
um
in authorized unauthorized um just kind
of going up and uh
you know i i actually
as as i'm growing up i don't remember
that
like this is exposed to it because um
you had to you had to be in the right
place at the right time i think like new
york or you know um the the the west
coast maybe we would have that would
that would have been on our radar but
growing up in the midwest right you know
um
you weren't gonna see that and and
really our main exposure to music videos
i would say came through mtv you know
once that that was available
um
but there's this
fascinating stuff going on prior to mtv
there's there's one other video too that
i want to talk about that's a little bit
off the wall and we've talked about this
in some other sessions particularly in
relation to ronnie james dio and the
black sabbath d purple thing
so there was a rock opera called the
butterfly ball and the grasshoppers
feast and originally it was supposed to
be john lord's project but roger glover
ended up taking it over because john
lord got cut busy with stuff
it was it was first a concept album and
then it was a live rock opera
and then it got set to video and a
cartoon
and the best part about this
is you've got all these like big name
stars who are circling around the the
you know black sabbath deep purple and
other things axis
um singing on it like ronnie james dio
or david coverdale and that you know
musicians playing but it's like a frog
hopping around so the rowdy dreams deal
part that became very very popular is
this frog playing basically like a you
know an old loot and singing this kind
of schmaltzy song
about
about love um it's uh what was i trying
to find the the actual name uh i think
it's like love yeah love is all um
and this became really big in a kind of
weird way
um the clip got used by fran one of
france's main um
uh tv channels and they would use it for
what's called interstitial stuff so you
you know you you run out of content you
got four minutes get four minutes to
kill throw it in there right
and they did it in australia too
on um one on on which was it they're the
austral australian broadcast uh company
they used it and it also showed up in
the australian music show countdown
because it became so popular and so when
ronnie james dio
arrived in australia there's an
interview of him and the host says oh we
all know who you are you know you've
never been here but we've all heard your
voice because you're the frog
and it like you know it's cause rainbow
was touring and rainbow hadn't been in
australia i think it was like 1977 or
78.
um
and this be you know this is a music
video it's kind of a crazy
essentially kids video but it's it's a
really important music video that got
probably the most play out of any video
in the 1970s because it was used in
these
these uh
things by french and australian um
companies
um
i mentioned countdown countdown was an
australian show
and one of the things
so you know ronnie james dio hadn't been
in australia why not because very few
bands would actually make it all the way
to australia they would you know tour
the us and europe and go to japan but it
cost a lot to bring sets down
and so the australians had their own i
won't say their own culture entirely but
a different um setup musically they had
they had shows and on these shows they
would play a lot of videos and so the
videos that were getting produced in
other places would would make their way
to australia and if you couldn't see
you know uh black sabbath live maybe you
can watch their video
now a lot of these videos were basically
just
the band playing you know with some
lights you know sometimes with some some
groovy effects you know uh from from the
psychedelic era um but they would play
a and and so australia was kind of ahead
of the curve
and um i mean ac dc's
success
some people think is is really
dependent on
shows like countdown um not just you
know having a good work ethic and
touring and things like that um
so um
what else should we say about this
should we take a pause for any questions
about about uh these developments i've
thrown a lot of stuff at people
um
we have a lot of other stuff but go
ahead go ahead skype well something
interesting the crossover and you you
just mentioned this early on
i remember when mtv started do you
remember if there was heavy metal
uh
most of the stuff was either
the band limps lip syncing into like in
a studio or it was an actual live
performance from the 70s
so
heavy metal uh well i remember the you
know uh see you in hell right the grim
reaper one
yeah that was like early on but any of
the heavy metal stuff it was kind of
like well we had to kind of wait i mean
it did it didn't take too long it's just
like a couple years for really heavy
narrative stuff to become
sort of like what was expected so you
could for at first you could get away
with just the band doing its its thing
and then after a while
and i'm gonna we'll bring up a couple
examples here like rainbows you know
great example you see them you know
their videos from the 70s and it's just
the band you know which is cool uh and
then by the time you get to like street
of dreams there's like a whole intro
sequence right
yeah and like a psychiatrist talking to
a guy for a minute before the video
actually begins and there's credits at
the start you know so um mark says i'm
curious how would you compare the impact
on music videos
of mtv versus youtube so that's a good
question i mean when when
mtv first came out
for it you know it wasn't something
radically new as we pointed out but it
was radically new for
um the mass audience in the united
states and and in other places i think
in britain as well
and it was in mtv
yeah and it was um
you know suddenly you had access to all
this stuff i mean i remember getting to
watch mtv we didn't have cable when i
was a kid but my uncle john in chicago
did you know because chicago was a much
bigger market and he liked to he he was
an early adopter of technology so even
though he he hated the stuff that was on
mtv he had it and when we were over at
his place we could watch it we'd be like
oh wow look at look at this you know
very little that originally was
metal i would say in like 1981 and 1982
but it then metals just took off on mtv
and it's so dominated um with requests
that they had to like make their own
little space for it but we're going to
talk about that in a subsequent uh class
now youtube right youtube is a massive
repository it's been around now
going like gangbusters what about 15
years about something like that
and there's a lot of metal stuff that's
loaded up there songs you know um
it was it was a way to discover a lot of
material that you
couldn't have seen
or you you you could have seen but you
didn't have access to back in the day
you know
well the i think the hugest difference
that this thing we have to make is the
purpose of mtv
was to sell records
right right okay the purpose of youtube
is not to sell records because people
aren't buying records it's almost kind
of like you know artists even bigger
artists are fighting to get anything
well put up a bunch of ads beforehand
and you can have a fraction of that so
you know the bands the metal bands that
you can discover and you know it you
know it's kind of like uh tv now you can
go to netflix and watch a show anytime
you want whereas like in the 80s we had
to be home by eight o'clock to see
something
you know like yeah yeah that's and we
had to wait a week for the next episode
to come out right yeah that's that's a
really great point um
youtube is a vast warehouse where you
can go in and get anything that you want
out but you have to know where to look
right
yeah and you don't have to um
the problem is it was
it's become
it's become that but it uh
we used to buy it like you know you see
this video of this great band on the new
whatever and you know you're mowing
lawns to save up money for that record
and you get your own very your very own
copy of that album and you know and
that's the whole kiss world right where
they'd have the
you know uh
and now it's it's kind of like yeah it's
it's almost like a library where you
have a free library card it doesn't cost
anything for you to see anything you
want i mean the there are a lot of bands
that
have merch
yes on
on the youtube things but those are the
bands that like have their act together
unfortunately a lot of the bands have
just sort of followed through the cracks
and and a lot of the stuff that got
loaded
in in the metal scene
um for more obscure bands is really kind
of a labor of love somebody had an
ep or an album and they played it on
their their phonograph and then they
converted it to digital and then you
know put some
maybe they just put the album art or
they put some
some images there and that's how we can
hear bands like leather wolf you know
um because somebody or dark star or pic
pick any of these you know more obscure
bands that um
now you can actually find in
apple music or in other things but for a
long time you couldn't as a matter of
fact i i list you know tank the uh
the great
new wave of british heavy metal band a
lot of their stuff is still not
available on
apple music
it's probably not available in the other
streaming things as well and so if you
want to hear like the full honor album
you have to go to youtube
and listen to the individual tracks that
people have uploaded and some of them
are better quality and some of them are
worse you know
yeah i mean there's there's something to
be said for you know
you and i always talk about the
importance early on we talk about the
importance of bass yeah so people are
listening on their phone
or on their computer speakers well
they're not getting the spectrum of
sound that i think we've agreed that is
a lot of the sound of heavy metal of
having that low end punch right even if
it's vinyl
the live but you know you're not uh i
tell a lot of my students like you know
mp3s through your thing you're not
getting the
uh
yeah you're not getting the sonic
experience of what was intended
let me ask you a question um that's sort
of
taking us way into left field
um
so going to concerts and
hearing you know most of the amps that
are there are just for show nowadays and
most things are going through the pa and
being mixed are are we losing are we
losing anything by not having you know
an actual wall
of amps that are that are really working
um compared to you know it going through
a pa
well we could go back to the 70s and
that was you know the blackboard none of
those there was one of those plexis
when he had and van halen with the big
wall one of those or two of them were
plugged in
in the time 23 marshals on stage but two
are on
[Laughter]
so uh
as far as in that case why not just have
like fake cabinets you know
um so much easier for the road crew you
know
van halen did they were empty
like if you look at the old van halen
pictures it's like the wall of the
cabinets behind yeah um they're empty um
you you so what was happening was there
was a lot of stage volume or yeah
i mean some bands may try to go direct
but you know you'll see mike's in front
of the amps even in the 70s and what
they're doing is they're mixing the
whole thing to the crowd so you're not
missing that
uh it's not like um
any of the classic metal bands we're
talking about like we're going digital
it's just like the wall of amps looked
cool but 100 watt marshall was going to
be plenty enough mic'd up so you're
still getting that sound you're still
getting the bass through the
eggs i think you and i always said like
with the bass the old amp eggs pushing
the tubes a little bit as a nice growl
lemmy
you know that overdrives i you know i
actually then again total
trivia off off kilter i found out
something kind of interesting through
watching all these you know
videos um
lemmy
didn't intend to be a bassist he joined
hawkwind as a guitarist but he sucked as
a guitarist and so they they put him
over on bass and he said well that's
where i found my
my calling you know
but and that's part of why he he played
bass you know using some guitar things
like playing chords you know using
essentially three tone chords um
uh mostly just power chords right um
on on the bass
and uh it's kind of interesting to find
that out you know he also got to sing a
bit on on uh
um
hawkman's stuff
he wasn't the main singer but
yeah
well let's let's uh
come back to topic
yes so music videos prior to mtv
we talked a little bit about the beatles
already right and the beatles some of
their stuff was pretty
sophisticated
um there were some other bands that that
did things that are essentially music
videos so if you think about bob dylan
and that famous uh song subterranean
homesick blues where he's holding up the
cards that's a music video right yeah
animals did a really cool thing
um the house of the rising sun they're
all dressed in the same basic outfits
and they're they're just sort of walking
around kind of looking menacing yes
they're doing it so there's no plot or
anything um but it it it's not just the
band sitting there right there's some
there's some movement there's some
development
um iron butterfly did uh
they did two different versions of
inaugurated vida the first one was in
1968 and it was it we see it in black
and white but that's because it was
actually done in that
red that old red blue 3d
stuff if you remember the old 3d movies
yeah
and the video track was actually
recorded at ultrasonic studios so it was
it was it was just a long island that is
kind of a high production thing
and then they did a 1969 color track of
the same thing
steppenwolf did a magic carpet ride they
did a video for that and there's there's
some narrative elements it's not you
know it's not like the the videos that
we're used to seeing where
you know
there's like a whole story being being
worked out or something like that and
then you know when i looked at the the
big key early metal bands they they did
some videos too black sabbath did a
video for paranoid that they filmed in
belgium in 1970
a very famous one very nice and it's
funny just an
option
the interesting thing about the videos
that were done that far back
so um
uh you know everybody was using pretty
much marshalls but orange amplifiers
were also a british amp company and if
you look in that video
um tony naomi's playing through an
orange amp
to this day orange uses that
as like look you know the one of the
masters used it you know our amps early
on
and as it turns out it just happened to
be an amp in the studio
you know that he you know it wasn't his
amp but
but it's funny how we go back to these
videos and and the companies are still
like oh look at tradition look at
zeppelin's song remains the same which
is a movie yeah right that's that's
actually a great point i mean having the
video footage
allows you to pick out things that
otherwise would be lost to time right
exactly and you know we used to do that
because jimmy page had all the marshalls
in the movie song remains the same but
he had that orange head on the end and
we were always like what's he using that
for
you know what's using that for so yeah
so i mean
short of buying a ticket at our young
age and getting front row
at least with these movies and these
appearances you know we could see what
our heroes were using we could see
kind of how it was done if there was a
live video not the
yeah
that's another great point though i mean
um having videos as in addition of
course having albums and all the other
stuff allows us to participate in
something of a culture that we couldn't
have participated in you know 1970 i was
born right um
and so
you know obviously
i i didn't know anything about black
sabbath until i was a good bit older
really the first heavy metal bands that
i
ran across were probably uh ac dc and
kiss you know there's debates about
whether they're truly heavy metal or not
but i'm willing to call them that yeah
but you know so going going on with this
the black sabbath they had a couple
other really important ones too they did
iron man um which is the band just
playing but some trippy psychedelic
images backdropped in there so it's not
just the band playing sam with bloody
sabbath actually it's it's a terrible
video but it's a video
it's the band playing right and then
they have like you know a dog
they have hiking they have like shooting
arrows one of them shoots an arrow into
the other guy
they have a lot of like focus on the
faces there's uh there's uh
bill ward drinking a beer a big stein up
here and you know it was i guess it was
felt like that was like you know
capturing something important they also
had another one that made a lot of
rounds nib which is probably one of my
favorite sabbath songs you know i love
that
yeah
so there's
there's a video of them playing it and
this is a live video right uh paris 1970
um and so you got kind of like the whole
gamut with black sabbath really early
black sabbath
they don't do a hell of a lot of other
videos throughout the 70s but once mtv
comes on they start doing them like
think about trashed off of the 1983
uh born again there's a whole story
there and it's not again not a great
video in terms of production
that an album unfortunately wasn't a
great album in terms of production but
it's it's doing what what videos did
ufo uh had some some interesting ones
um and again early stuff in the 70s
right boogie if you've ever heard boogie
for george
there's a uh one of one of the shows
that we're going to talk about beat club
it was a german show
they did a thing with the band on stage
and they have all this crazy trippy
background stuff going on that must have
taken a lot of uh lights expertise at
the time
and you know you could imagine this
being played in bars and places like
that
they had
another one from their early stuff
prince kaijuku off of ufo2
black and white band playing with groovy
visual effects
uriah heap got into it again off of a
band show another german band show the
lady in black is one that you can find
which is really well quite well done uh
it's kind of funny to see some of the
people dancing
um to this stuff because you know if you
think about uh
metal sensibilities how much they've
changed deep purple um has a video of
highway star and there's also this like
important live smoke on the water
recorded um
video in japan
that would circulate around and then i i
found hawkwind has uh from the the lemmy
era with talia too if if you don't know
the story of talia uh with with hawk
when she was a dancer who just sort of
like showed up and started dancing and
she was uh um very tall very busty and
often would take off all of her clothes
and there's a really funny story that's
told by
i can't remember who it is but he says
that like she you know she it was the
early 70s she would dance around naked
or with body paint and after a while
people didn't really pay attention to
that they would actually watch her if
she went to put on her clothes and that
would be the thing that they would be
focusing on so that was like in
hawkman's really you know uh seedy era
and there's a video silver machine
that was a promo used for top of the
pops and it's got
lemmy playing and singing
bubbles crowd shots so a lot of visual
elements that that you know take you
beyond just the the music track right or
just the concert experience
um you know then we get to some bands
that people don't consider metal anymore
but were
in the 1970s associated with heavy metal
grand funk railroad um they have a video
for word american band
and it's the band playing but then it's
also them riding around on dirt bikes on
motorcycles there's even a sequence with
a horse for one guy
um arguably there's no narrative there
but it you know it's like look at how
cool we are getting around
and then there's queen
bohemian rhapsody
that was a video that that again
developed in part because they wanted to
play it on top of the pops
and the band did not think that they
would be able to do anything like the
choreography they wanted to so they had
it done
with a video
and it's the iconic stuff that you know
the faces right all showing up together
in the choral parts
now we're getting to a level of
sophistication that goes beyond just a
band on a stage or
a guy is running around on motorcycles
or something like that right
and then we get to kiss
and here we we have something
quite different they started doing promo
videos all the way back in 1975 for rock
and roll all night
and then if you haven't seen hard luck
woman which is one of the few tracks
that peter chris sings on
um 1976 it's it's focused on him at the
drum set
and it's very you know i mean it's not
as schmaltzy as beth i would say
but it's it's pretty close what would
you say scott yeah yeah we'll give it a
we'll give it a tie there
yeah i mean it wasn't wasn't peter chris
responsible for beth too i think
um
or am i mixed up about that wasn't he
writer on that one
you know i i don't know that i i don't
know if it was like you know i want to
sing a song or
yeah well once you know once he was gone
they didn't do it forever and now what's
his name has been singing at the uh why
did i forget the stanley i think right
no the drummer um oh does he uh tom not
tommy thayer uh
eric nope
nope no is it eric carr i think so yeah
what happened to the guy with the long
blonde hair
did he leave um that might be a couple
couple drummers ago
wow well hopefully it didn't blow up
like on uh yeah i don't know i was gonna
say
yeah
in any case um so they're they're making
videos right and you can see a progress
in their videos you know the stuff the
promo videos for rock and roll all night
it's cool stuff to watch you know it's
kissing their makeup and you know so it
could be an experience for those of us
who didn't get to see it all of us kids
and and yeah there was tons and tons of
stuff kiss figure if kiss meets the
phantom of the park
um which is it marks it or chris says
it's the ultimate music video in a way
it's it's like um an extended music
video right um sort of like you know if
you had queens right operation minecraft
it's basically a concept album with a
lot of mixed up stuff and kiss i think
they had a crossover with scooby-doo as
well
um
there's all sorts of things that kiss
gets their their fingers into they do
but what i wanted to say
by the time they get to the disco era
you know if i was made with uh for
loving you sure knows something off the
dynasty
yeah
1979 so still pre-mtv
really really crisp visuals compared to
the previous stuff so they're like
upping their game they know that
something is is coming they're not doing
narratives yet
but um
they're clearly doing something of
interest
we can also talk about a couple other
bands ram jam are they metal well not
really
some people consider them southern rock
but they're metal adjacent they have a
funny music video for black betty it's
just a bunch of guys out in front of a
house
like like
in a subdivision somewhere
playing or playing a rock show
uh lots of zooming in on the very
unattractive uh guitarist and singer um
clearly pre-mtv right
rainbow as i mentioned you know long
live rock and roll they recorded three
clips with ronnie james deal la
connection gates of babylon and long
live rock and roll it's just the band
but if we compare that to the mtv era
their their stuff
once deal leaves and once um
you know blackmore is able to steer the
band in the direction he wants it gets
it gets very very sophisticated um
stories you know that are that are being
worked out
motorhead they do some videos but their
stuff is basically just the band playing
on stage they they never do an awful lot
um
van halen did uh videos uh promo videos
with you know for running with the devil
jamie's crying you really got me just
just the band
loss of control which is off of is it is
it women and children first or diver
down uh 1980 um do you remember scott
uh that would be
uh no women and children first right i
think so yeah yeah that has some
narrative um
it's david lee roth of course the you
know ultimate front man um who's being
video video recorded and he's there with
some some attractive woman and he
there's like a whole sort of narrative
sequence to it
um scorpions are another important band
um
the stuff that they're doing in the
by 1980 just the band playing by the
if you look at 1982
um no one like you it's an entire story
it's even got the guy you know the
famous forks guy right yeah um now yeah
like chris morrissey points out uh jump
is video genius
by that time van halen has embraced the
the video
what would you call it video medium
right it's no longer just promotional
clips they know that mtv is is the way
to go
judas priest is kind of a funny one
um living after midnight has the band
and concert shots and they weren't doing
they were they were doing video
appearances we were going to talk about
some of these shows that they were on
but they weren't doing videos for videos
breaking the law which is off of the
same album there's an entire narrative
if you haven't seen the video for it
it's it's really something um it's kind
of cheesy from today's
standards but i think it actually kind
of holds up
it's got the band first of all it's got
rob helford you know riding around
singing about how he's out of work
endowed he's in a car he looks you know
like he's he's kind of unhappy
and then the band robs a bank with their
guitars
i mean you can't you know
whoever came up with this it's really
quite great
and then you know 1981 the year that mtv
is starting to come out
they do heading out to the highway
and first the band is playing be in
front of a painted desert backdrop
like a southwest sort of scene and then
there's a road race with classic cars
with rob halford being the guy waving
the flag and stuff like that
so
they they knew what they were doing
video wise before mtv
really starts to to offer them new
things i mean it's not as sophisticated
as what they're doing on um
you know 1983
um
in 1984 and 1985 uh i'm blanking we got
defenders of the faith screaming for
vengeance and turbo right those those
albums they're really upping their game
as well
rush did an interesting uh thing for tom
sawyer
if you haven't seen that video it's well
worth checking out because getty lee
plays three
three things it's like shooting back and
forth between the band and they're in a
studio that's in a house and you can see
the outside which is all winter
and uh getty lee is singing he's playing
bass and he's also playing the keyboards
yeah kind of a captivating composition i
always really liked that video and you
know the story behind that that's their
famous studio that they recorded their
albums
okay so um there was a certain thing
that was for fans that were we were kind
of invited into the studio
um
that we've only heard about oh yeah yeah
and like on the album cover i don't know
if you had the album it would have kind
of pictures of them in that studio like
in the past albums and for once now we
see them sitting in there
which i think you know is the album
that put all their exp other
experimenting together yeah you you know
you know in the past it was like
weird time changes this this they're
experimenting but on that album there's
a lot of odd time signature but it goes
with the lyrics it goes with the song so
as a kid i didn't realize there was any
weird time shifts so i i kind of came
together and it was like a perfect i
think it's great that you brought them
up because that was like a a really cool
one i think that's a really great point
though that you're making about it it's
inviting the
the fan right because heavy metal has
always been about the connection between
musician and fan
um as opposed to some other genres where
maybe the fans aren't as valued and
creating community isn't as valued so
bringing them into your studio
that's really quite interesting chris
morrissey points out uh less studio more
in heights quebec
um published in 2020.
thank you chris yeah that's that's
that's right and
in in not to stop this but
you've left out one of the most
ah
i want to say ridiculous
videos but so ridiculous is funny would
be motley cruise too young to fall in
love
now this video
um
they go in uh motley crew and they're
full leather
and
they're trying to save a woman
and there's all these ninjas that are
like doing sword things like this and
like 96 would just go punch the guy in
the face and he'd be knocked out and
yeah it was kind of like they could
barely move in their clothes but like
ninjas couldn't stop them and but by
this time we're like heavily into the
mtv era right that's right yeah i mean
you know technically motley crew could
have created a music video with their uh
early 1981 not full album right
uh it was an ep but i don't think they
did i couldn't i didn't see any any i
mean they have there's video footage of
them playing in like
clubs and stuff
right right
um but the band that i really wanted to
get to sort of like bring this to a
close with is acdc
interestingly they they were ahead of
their time
and then they moved away from narrative
because if you look at there's like
three videos that are really i would say
iconic
um
one is them playing it's a long way to
the top uh on on tv in studio and that
one it doesn't have a narrative but
watching bon scott like stop and then
play the bagpipes that that's got this
visual element to it and then all the
kids are dancing around them but they
have two uh videos that and these would
be playing on that countdown show
jailbreak so jailbreak is 1976 and it is
a full narrative right it starts out
with bond scott singing and all that and
the different band members play
different roles some of them are guards
some of them are prisoners and there is
a jailbreak that takes place and there's
like you know killing and stuff like
that and then there's let there be rock
which has bond scott dressed up like
basically like a a priest
and he's preaching a sermon which is a
story if you've ever heard it there's
like a litany of like first there was
this and then this happened and then
this happened it's almost like the
easter
um litany in in uh you know churches um
first this happened then this happened
and and he's he's reciting something
that's secular but it's in a
poking fun at religious way
and it cuts to shots of the band but a
lot of it is bond scott at the pulpit
um so it's not so much that there is a
narrative like guys running around doing
stuff like you know breaking the law you
know robbing a place or right jail but
there is a narrative that somebody is in
costume telling you about
when you look at the stuff that they're
doing in 1979 or
with back and black in 1980 it's just
band performances and it's cool stuff
but they stop doing
narrative and i i don't know why i i
mean i'm sure there's probably
interviews out there
that explain it maybe they thought ah
it's a little bit too over the top it's
easier just to like record us
playing um well you know not to
interrupt but like this is a great point
because
um
you know i watch a lot of interviews
from the year that the albums come out
so yeah not not the band now so
um they're not metal at all but
you know uh aryo speedwagon is one of
the bands that did that so if you
remember um you know keep on loving you
he was in the he was in this therapist's
chair and and then they tried to have
all these narratives for the uh high
infidelity album and then when they were
promoting the next album good trouble
there was like a mtv did this you know
hour documentary on it and all of the
videos were them playing it not live but
lip syncing it okay and they said well
you know they had gary and and um
and kevin on and they said well you know
what happened to the videos like where
you were telling a story yeah and kevin
cronin says you know
that's not me i i'm not an actor i can't
lay on there and talk about this girl
that was supposed to break up with me
for three minutes before the song starts
and we just think this is
more of who we are we're a live band we
we look good live and it's kind of uh
and so they decided every song on the
next album although of course their next
album after that they went back to the
suspending reality kind of videos
um that might be a product of like you
know mtv
not
it's not like mtv ever like went around
and went to musicians and they were like
you better have a narrative or something
like that there was but but i think mtv
by
its very nature and the fact that other
people were doing narrative videos they
put pressure on advance to
start thinking about how they would do
that you know i wonder if it was mtv or
i think the a r people
from the record companies would make the
decisions
um i don't know how much payola was
going on in mtv but
um
i don't i think mtv you know if it flop
they wouldn't play it
or um
you know i think you know everything
came from the record company you're
gonna show yourself this way you're
gonna this is what the kids like right
now or this is what the what's happening
and um but we do see it like you say the
quality starts changing by the time
we're you know in 86 and 87
we've got some really good filtering on
the
they look like movies now yeah
yeah i mean it it's like standards that
kept increasing and i would say also not
just in terms of the technical
production
but your narrative needed to make sense
um i'll actually you know we weren't
really going to talk that much about the
mtv era but there there are some videos
out there
that are worth looking at because
they're so terrible
and one of them
is thor's song anger a song that i
actually like quite a bit
but it is probably the the hokiest
cheesiest video that you can find
and dio did some real stinkers you know
oh yeah
in in some of the early videos but this
thor video
oh it's just awful thor was a guy he's a
canadian artist right and he he he was
like sort of the center of the band and
he was a big guy big tough guy
bodybuilder he'd do things like
ben barz in his his show on stage and
like he interestingly blow up water
bottles like you know like for a hot
water bottle and he'd explode them to
show his lung capacity
so anyway it's like a sword and sorcery
thing
it's got a wizard in it it's got a war
here
it's just awful you know you look at it
and you're like if i saw this this might
actually turn me off from wanting to buy
the album you know
that's a really good point
that's a really good point and i wonder
how many times that happened to us where
you couldn't get past the visual right
the music's kind of clouded by the
um
but but just to jump back really quick
before we get totally off topic of
pre-mtv
um
one of the things that uh i was looking
into
was
uh
it was kind of like remember how ed
sullivan was like mr out of touch but
like here's these great boys the beatles
yeah
and he you know he probably hated the
music well in the 70s and even through
the mid 80s
metal bands or or aor rock bands would
go on tv shows and i remember seeing
yeah
one where blue oyster cult was on when
fire of unknown origin came out in 81
and it's interesting because
you know the the interviewer is as
stuffy as you can get you know the guy
that's hosting the show i don't know who
you guys are and then um there was
always this element of you know he would
ask these questions about devil warship
he would ask about you know volume he
would ask about the drugs he would ask
about
and and this is what heavy metal was but
you know
eric bloom were well spoken and kind of
you know answered and so he goes well
this is really interesting to me because
i know you're going to play uh one of
your new songs in a minute which is part
of it he goes but you know i thought you
know
i didn't think i was going to talk to
gentlemen like you it's like i'm talking
to simon and garfunkel and
so but like all these shows were like
the super stuffy guy that had to have
these metal bands on because the kid was
kids wow you could tell that they could
not stand
you know but it was like however the
deals worked out it was individual mtv
you would watch a tv show like saturday
night live would have a certain band on
or you know in the 70s
you know and there there were also like
uh daytime talk shows that would bring
you like paul stanley and uh oprah
yeah uh
gene simmons right and then wendyl
williams went on quite a few you know
and uh i think she was done like sally
jessie rafael or something like that
um
it was always controversial though it
was always to bring them yeah and and
some of them would be like you're saying
with louise or call like you know
they'd they'd be like listen we're not
nut jobs and then you know like when
wendy or williams would go on she or you
know gene simmons would go on then
they'd like really play it up you know
um there's also the robert downey shoot
junior show you and i watched that clip
with ace freely where he's clearly drunk
coming in you know
drunk shot if he loved it yeah yeah and
uh he goes on and he's talking about
freedom of expression and stuff like
that and actually being quite quite
interesting uh but every once in a while
just like lapsing into giggling and
stuff like that so so you know i mean
they weren't playing on the show but
um
i guess it was a way to like see the
persona of of bands right
and i also think the tv shows were
starting to find out that metal was
starting to be huge and if they wanted
the young art audience to turn up turn
it on for you know
yeah ratings
i think about the same
like metal and punk both kind of
migrated in together that way you know
they were both uh movements that the
squares didn't really get but they knew
were important nadia has a a
point about solitary sun in memory of us
it was all in the ocean i'm thinking
this has to do with the videos that were
terrible uh
topic right um because i i'm not sure
who solitary sun is do you know that
reference
no
memory of us
i don't know though i mean there are
some pretty bad videos out there um and
the further we go back you know like you
like what scott was saying like by six
you know uh 86 87
you kind of had to have your crap
together in terms of making videos but
before that it was like anything goes
well we noddy and i make fun of the
benny margolis into the night video
which is
confusing and scary it was 1977. it's it
was a video with a whole story you know
him at the phone booth and this girl's
like 16 years old and his father said
leave her alone and we watch it in
horror because we're like
this is and then they're on magic carpet
at the end and she looks so unimpressed
and bored and
[Laughter]
so daddy says that the the rock band
that plays their instruments in the
ocean yeah that that's a problem that's
a
problem that is a problem
yeah
oh my gosh
yeah let's let's let's move back to
uh
so we were talking about shows right um
and there are quite a few bands early on
that show up in the narrative or
background of films or tv shows and i
i'm just going to give you a few
examples um the animals we talked about
before they're in a movie
in 1965 and they play we got to get out
of this place and they're they're there
in the background and they play the
whole song
right it's part of the the movie as
opposed to like what what normally
happens where the band starts and then
like you know you shift back to the
action
right um paul revere and the raiders my
dad was a huge fan of them so so i you
know i got to listen to them a lot as a
kid they were on batman in in 1966 and
got to play like a full song you know
again
i think this is kind of important when
you get to play a whole song alice
cooper shows up in a whole bunch of
places in the early 70s including on the
snoop sisters
um
kiss performed
detroit rock city for the paul lindy
halloween special
um kiss you know in the phantom of the
park is sort of a landmark thing people
love it or hate it
um another like ships and wonder woman
would have bands in there
um rick springfield plays in kind of
like stage makeup almost like kiss uh
there's this fictional band anti-matter
on on wonder woman and the things that
were done it was people like trying to
portray what they thought a punk or
heavy metal band was like oh yeah ships
has has a kiss-like band called moloch
and they also have another like made-up
punk band called payne and they they're
like at battle of the bands and you know
of course these are supposed to be the
bad guys you know um they're they're not
the
chips episode where they come in for
questioning and this is such a setup
right so they they they come in to
question some people but there's a it's
like in a in a mill and there's a band
plane and it's like what they thought
kids were in so they're playing and then
they put a close-up of the guitar's
hands doing this real cheesy tap thing
because tapping was in because of eddie
van gaal
and they're like okay guys take five and
it was
it was like
you know it's like you know okay now
they want a question but they gave this
band a good like three minutes
of like what they thought like a rock
band a cool rock band was you know it's
kind of funny because that probably you
couldn't do that today in a show right
unless it's actually focusing on
that band like the the k the band leader
is an important character in the show or
something like that
well yeah i mean there was a lot of uh
uh miss editing or
like filler
or you know
they didn't quite know how to make their
points suddenly you know it's kind of
like well the kids seem to like this
rock and roll thing let's
you know let's put it in it'll be cool
yeah um
but it's it's it's funny yeah about all
the shows um
what's another
i just thought of one too you're naming
some great ones but like they would
actually have well didn't that happen in
some cartoons too
well i mean kiss me like i pointed out
kiss made it into scooby-doo you know
that's right
um but i think there are probably others
i mean there were lots of non-metal
bands that had crossovers like that like
the partridge family you know
um yeah and then there were like with
kids cartoons there were cartoons that
were about bands as well
oh josie and the pussycats
yeah yeah and then that had to become
that preceded
like the band and then the movie came
out what in the late 90s
and then it was uh k hanley that was
that and then they actually did a small
tour as josie of the busy house did they
really
yeah but think about movies like
nightmare nightmare on elm street which
is where we learned about all the new
metal bands
right yeah dawkin like
major bank from uh dreamworks the third
one yeah yeah um
yeah that's a good point yeah yeah i
mean showing up in soundtracks
well there was that one that um
i don't remember the name of it but
fastway
did like the entire soundtrack to it
and it had gene simmons and ozzy
osbourne in it
really it was a horror movie i'm just
blanking on on the name
i think if i remember right gene simmons
plays like a preacher or i might be
mixing up with ozzy osbourne and that i
just remember him in runaway
okay
where he played the bad guy with tom
selleck
he was in um quite a few shows okay
um
i i you know i mean
more power to him he's uh
i guess he's a multi-talented guy um
well let's let's go back to ta so
another kind of show that i wanted to
talk about
and uh i'm glad that we have nadia here
uh because she can offer some of her
insight so shows were bands uh playing
or
playing videos featured centrally
there's a whole vast variety of them
obviously like you weren't you weren't
going to get on solid gold as a metal
band right because it was devoted to a
whole different kind of thing
and some of these were like just music
shows and some of them were variety
shows some of them focused primarily on
the band some of them included the
audience dancing
um
so
the i would say that the three biggest
like centers for these were the united
states britain and germany
britain had a vast variety of these top
of the pops has just a you know you you
look at the number of bands that have
appeared on there
it's uh just
there's so many that have been on there
especially metal bands um
and you know a good example of this cozy
sometimes it would be like you know cozy
powell he was on there in 74 with cozy
powell's hammer that you know nobody
listens to anymore but he had bernie
marsden on guitar uh in in that band and
don airy on keyboard so you know some
some significant talent um a lot of
bands showed up on top of the pops the
other massively important one was the
old gray whistle test
oh yeah and that was different than top
of the pops in that it focused primarily
on albums so you'd play some songs from
your album but it was you had a new
album
out
alice cooper showed up on that
jimi hendrix cream did their farewell
concert on it wishbone ash urai heap
judas priest a whole bunch of
bands
and then there were some other ones as
well that are worth pointing out there
was one called revolver that was mostly
oriented towards punk but they did have
david coverdale
in the early white snake years on that
one
giving a performance
rock goes to school
not not particularly oriented towards
metal but had ac dc and ian gillen when
he had his own band called gillen after
deep purple and then there was one
called extra celestial transmission
which would have have bands play two or
three songs live
and that one was really important for
the new wave of british heavy metal it
had motorhead
girl school
wasted
tigers of pantang
venom
and then a lot well warlock and then a
lot of other bands that are more obscure
like um tollbrook or
chariot or persian risk you know that
people don't really
know that much um now nadia says the
tube were huge too so that that one i
didn't uh look at did they have a lot of
metal stuff on on the tube that's that's
uh a good question
um
you know also in this time there's a lot
of like blending back and forth is this
metal is this punk you know what is this
uh it's not it's not as if there was
ever a hard and fast um
line between them
well you know what's funny actually
nadio
was on a tv show called number 73 which
broke bands
i don't think that there were more more
uh new wave bands i think she can tell
you better but yeah the premise of the
show is
there was roommates that lived at number
seven apartment 73 in every episode
uh a van a band would their van would
break down on the way to the gig
so they'd have to come in and rehearse
at their place
so so there's a narrative but it's the
same narrative every single time right
but it's a new band that they that's
kind of funny yeah i mean well
after a while you'd think somebody would
get wise and be like um
why why are they always breaking down
here you know there must be something
about it are they laying out like you
know call
trops somebody says
oh yeah it was uh the 80s presented by
jules holland and uh paula yates i
didn't i don't know of that okay cool
yeah
um
going to american stuff
there was one called in concert
and the only metal band that they
actually featured was alice cooper and
they stopped featuring stuff like that
because it created a massive scandal
when it was airing in cincinnati which i
guess was pretty you know
conservative at that time
the station manager yanked it off the
air and substituted uh an episode of
bonanza for the for the show and then
that was the end of that but there were
two other ones that were really uh quite
important don kirchner's rock concert
huge had black sabbath bleister cult
alice cooper kiss montrose rainbow rush
ufo uriah heap van halen and zebra on on
them at one time or another so you know
all 70s well zebra that'd be 80s
then there was the midnight special and
they they had ac dc aerosmith and thin
lizzy but you can notice it's kind of
slim pickings prior to mtv
for metal appearances in the american
venue compared to the british venue the
german venue is something quite
different
they had a show that was originally
called beat club and then it became
music laden
and
the the list i won't read all of them
but there's there's a lot so beat club
had black sabbath blue cheer alice
cooper cream deep purple jimi hendrix
you know we could go on and on with like
these 19
proto metal bands and then 1970s metal
bands music laden had iron maiden
motorhead
nazareth the plasmatics you know with
wendia williams scorpions twisted sister
on and then there was there were other
like smaller
german things one was uh sylvester
taunts party you know dance party right
and it's kind of fun one of the as
leading a little bit of strain one of
the funny things about this
is when you look at these old videos so
you don't usually think about heavy
metal and then be like dance party you
know or heavy metal jazz beat
or heavy metal disco you know um but you
know
these these music terms were just kind
of floating around out there and i think
there was kind of a feeling
in the 70s that you should at least be
able to dance to this music it wasn't
all head banging and stuff like that at
least for these shows you know
um and so there were some other ones you
know denmark had jazz beat uh austria
had had spotlight netherlands had top
pop uh it's at a top of the pops just
top pop but they had you know black
sabbath and finn lizzie and def leppard
and the runaways on there and then
australia as i put it out had countdown
and countdown
that was a really important show because
it was aggregating music videos and it
was just playing that or bans local
bands getting up and lip syncing to
and so it was a way to do proof of
concept for mtv before mtb came on in a
way
right where these others were
foundering
and a lot of uh international acts
who would not have otherwise been heard
on australian commercial radio would get
exposure in australia through countdown
sort of like how with metal you know if
if we were listening to our local radio
stations in the
you know the 70s we might hear some some
stuff but there's a lot of stuff that we
wouldn't hear like
um
you know you might hear the scorpions
but not iron maiden yeah um and so these
these uh shows i think were really quite
an important
venue for for getting stuff out for
people just like you know with other
stuff like there was a dr demento show
that i think many of us have listened to
oh yeah if you want to hear crazy
goofy music well you weren't going to
hear that on the regular commercial
radio stations but you could you could
hear it on the dr demento show right so
right
yeah remember that
nadia points out dire straits and the
police both started on a show called all
right now in london i i kind of get the
idea that there was like a vast universe
of these these shows some of which
may not have run for more than like one
series
because you know there wasn't enough
money behind it or they didn't get
enough eyeballs or something like that
that we we we just haven't like dug into
enough you know
um
but it's it's remarkable just
looking at this how much
as we were kids and didn't know any any
of this stuff going on how much of this
stuff was
going on and contributing to this
this uh entire universe of of music
you know which
escada often talks about how the music
business has changed and i think that
this is this is part of that right these
shows kind of going away
um
or you know music videos are music
videos really that important anymore
um
people promoting you know
well it's interesting because a lot of
people are making videos and they're
told you know we're talking like the
musical middle class not the yeah or
even the big ones are making videos but
the videos aren't
designed to sell product anymore that is
the product and it's kind of like okay
you know if if it's not going to convert
to people buying a ticket to your show
or buyer you know there are other
merchandise buttons but there's only so
many t-shirts people can buy or will buy
or
or or mugs or um
you know it
it's kind of an interesting thing i just
wanted to say with all this um
with the kind of trans media we're
talking about like with kiss meets the
phantom uh their their albums their
lunchboxes well the beatles started that
and i think this day and age if you
offer a show even like remember uh
people must be familiar with the velvet
underground and andy warhol right yeah
and they would perform at the factory in
new york and he would do his psychedelic
andy warhol would be do his cool visuals
and that was an event that people went
to
so there's something to say like we're
all talking about this stuff this this
okay it's not just the record how are we
gonna promote it or how are we gonna
have an experience so people are drawn
into our world well you know the kiss
world was a great one because they were
superheroes right they were comic book
characters and
um you never saw them and and it was
kind of a world we wanted to want to be
in the kiss army
right um
i think these ideas are all really good
ideas now to maybe get people to come in
well you've got something like i did a
show a week ago where there was like
these cool visuals like almost random
like video kind of things going on on
the walls and uh there was visual and
musical medium plus light show that you
couldn't experience on your phone you
have to like look around the room and
experience or focus in on something and
um
i think it's kind of interesting we're
talking about all the stuff how
initially drew people into record sales
maybe this is the kind of thing that we
draw people into venues with rather than
you know like we're talking about well
we can look up any video
uh and you mentioned the difference of
quality right so yeah a video on youtube
it might just be
you know uh not such it's not so great
quality and certainly not an experience
you know i think about like uh recent
shows that that we've gone to
think about in particular jewish priests
so judas priest
always has a
big screen with a lot of stuff going on
behind it tied to particular songs so
green man elisha will you're going to
see a green man alicia right but like
saints in hell has its own sequence and
um
it's it's kind of cool i mean some of
them are basically just loops of of
things right but some can be quite long
um now only they get to do it because
they're the main act so like we've seen
thin lizzie saxon
uh uriah heap
and i'm blanking on who else we've seen
with priests and obviously they don't
get to do that they they just get to
have like the the big um tapestry that
has like you know the band logo and
stuff like that on it um
and that's it you know um
[Music]
so it kind of depends on whether where
you fit in i mean the bands that are
touring with priests are
what you're
what was the term that you used like
middle middle class
well they're they're little they might
be a little higher if you're on tour
with priests you're not
you know trying to book a gig at your
local bar
so the the advantage yeah you better not
be
yeah so i think if you're opening for
priest yeah
you have an opportunity to kick ass in
front of 20 000 people that might go to
the merchant with the buyer thing
whereas somebody that's trying to play a
bar and bring 40 people in
well they don't have that captured
audience so they're going to have to do
something to to want to bring people in
where people are going to go see priests
if you're the opening act you have an op
well remember we we always joke about
when we were younger sometimes the the
opening act was more hungry yeah they'd
show up like docking with crocus was a
legendary one when i was in high school
um that was like the death knell for for
crocus at the time but it it was dark
and young and hungry you know
that's it kind of kind of been its best
you know and yeah and uh queens reich
did that who are they opening for um
and they just they were like wiping the
floor with the main act because they
were so
you know
there's quite a few of these where like
a band and that that actually might be
an interesting thing to talk about
sometimes like a topic there were quite
a few where a band would be exhausted
like black sabbath touring with kiss
right yeah and the black sabbath guys
were like these kiss guys they're just
you know way more dynamic than we are
you know
um
because they you know the black sabbath
guys were strung out on drugs by that
point
right that's true yeah and there might
be something too about like constant
touring that wears you down quite a bit
but
um so so rob had to had to leave and we
actually should start
wrapping this up before too long and and
we didn't uh get into too many like um
anything goes
questions from from the audience i don't
have any more more um like research
material to talk about
um
i don't do you use scott if not we can
just sort of open it up for general
questions yeah
that'd be cool
yeah if anybody has any uh
any things they want to say yeah or or
yeah that'd be great
and next time we'll we'll actually um
we're going to talk well next time we
pick up this topic i'm not sure if we're
going to jump into this uh for december
but we're going to talk about the mtv
era we might actually have to break that
into two sections too okay so mark says
ozzy or at least sharon
yeah the power behind the throne is
someone i feel has really used mtv in
interesting ways
yeah apart from music there were things
like the osborne's which almost
foreshadows the impact social media
would have on the artist audience
relationship
that's that's quite true um and i think
that's entirely attributable to sharon
i mean well that's interesting because
now we're talking about post mtv is the
reality show jesus did it the fit was it
family duels exactly
um
although people call
tend to call that the uh what the how
many steps gradation to hell like you
know first you appear on celebrity
boxing and then
level levels of hell like that you mean
or it's not something like that like you
just it's kind of like your fall from
grace it's like you start grabbing onto
reality shows yeah i don't know i don't
know how much we all believe that but um
but yeah i mean
of course they're scripted but we didn't
care we want to see ozzie walk around
completely in a drug state right yeah
bumping into walls
um i mean i will say this about sharon
and this is this is stuff coming from
like bob daisley and jk lee and don airy
and it's not about like how how they
ripped them off the people who actually
wrote the music
um jk lee stuck around after bo after
was bob dave no bob daisley wasn't on
ultimates and he was on uh bark at the
moon
and then they're they're gone
and already by then they're dressing
kind of weird you know for like their
stage shows if you see the the stuff
that's all sharon she insisted on the
outfits and by the time that they're on
the ultimate sin and doing the the
videos for that they just look
ridiculous it's like wearing blouses and
it's
the worst yeah it's very glam but jk lee
looks like crap too
and people asked him about it he's like
listen i didn't she told me if i want to
be you know if i want to be in the video
if i want to be on tour if i want to be
hired i got to wear this crap you know
with the big shoulder pads and
he had the long coat and the chucks like
he was known for his ch is his chuck
taylors right yeah yeah
uh um
and and so you know
is when you look at the videos
i guess maybe at the time
a lot of people were like
well this seems cool you know um but
it it was so glammy you know
it wasn't ozzy i mean even at the time
it was kind of like i really loved that
album ultimate sin but i remember the
visuals were uncomfortable you know i
think my friends and i said it looks
like some old grandma
broke into grandma's wardrobe yes
exactly in the hair and it was just um
yeah i remember like it being a little
scary scene ozzy like that for me yeah
yeah there was there's phil susan and
bass and i don't remember who the
drummer was um but they all they all
looked like that and then lots of makeup
too you know oh yeah and it wasn't like
kiss makeup you know it was like
you know and it wasn't i mean motley
crue did the
uh on their you know on the shout out
the devil album they they did the
looking like like chicks kind of thing
but they did it in a way that was really
hard edged you know
right aussie ultimate sin did not have
that
no it was like definitely broken to
grandma's closet it didn't look it
wasn't edgy it was what was that thing
he was that the blouse thing he was
wearing was like sparkles and that's
right yeah sequins yeah thank you yeah
yeah i forgot about that
i had that video and it was just it
opened with um
the first track was the video for
um
uh
well what's what's the big song from
that album well they're all big but uh
it started out with that
shot
yeah and then uh ultimate sim video was
on there too
which was uh
kind of a funny video but really kind of
didn't it wasn't cool for us to see
ozzie look like that that's right yeah
yeah it was sort of a
moving away from
[Music]
darkness yeah yeah exactly yeah
i mean if you think about it so that is
what 1986
six okay so
around that time you have um judas
priest releasing ram it down
which is still kind of you know turbo
arrow stuff it's stuff they've recorded
for the turbo album and then put out but
they're starting to get harder again
right um iron maiden had you know not
that long before that released live af
after death and as a video performance
as well
um
who else do you have in the metal scene
that's really big at that time maybe
well except put out stay in a life
okay yeah yeah the live from tokyo right
yeah that was 85
which i love
yeah and the scorpions were still riding
hard on a touring like crazy uh after
blackout and worldwide live and then and
love it for sting which was 84.
so that's right live was 85. yeah and i
mean the other thing too is at that time
you've also got
like thrash metal
firmly established by 86 you know and
the whole pared down look because
not only has
metallica become big uh mega death is
also on the scene anthrax is on the
screen slayer's starting to move in
to it um so there's like a whole
different aesthetic of like we're not
going to be like those those you know
grandma's wardrobe you know glammy
people we're we're going to be like
really doing hard stuff so
yeah ultimate i mean it sounds good
but the visuals
i i yeah it was
it was a it's a great great album i love
that album and uh
visuals were i remember buying the
videos like i couldn't make these songs
done live
and then my i remember my friend and i
wat it was in his house you know we're
open and we throw it in we're like
oh what
you know
last we saw you you were like you know
the prince of darkness
yeah exactly yeah
well you can say this about for for
everything bad that we can say about
sharon osbourne
she is
clearly responsible for him not being
dead you know and not being dead in 84
and and stuff right does she she's the
one who uh
who uh would you know make him stop
drinking and taking drugs for a while i
mean it didn't stick a lot of the time
but no well there's famous videos in 86
of him sitting on the floor and then
trying to interview him you're like well
how is sobriety now that you're sober
he's like it's
effing terrible
and then he goes i need something to
drink that goes there's some water right
there he goes water
like he's like completely like you know
he he seems drunk in the thing so it
didn't really last at all but um
yeah he was having a tough time with
that
yeah well i mean
what a decade and a half of not being
you know sober i mean
black sabbath recruited him i think in
69 right
and it was just one long ride from that
point on so
yeah
i mean with ozzy you can't even just say
like you know cocaine's a hell of a drug
or pods
or something like he was trying at all
so you tried everything yeah oh my gosh
well it's a miracle he's still here you
know even 10 years ago i saw a sabbath
and he didn't seem alive on stage he was
just
we love you all and singing out a key
but
yeah i think i think i mean there are a
lot of uh great you know metal musicians
who are still um putting out excellent
stuff
you know innovative stuff
yeah maybe we should do an episode on
that as well you think about like so
judas priest you know judas priest has
has a fairly new album with firepower
saxon um
i'm trying to thunderbolt is their most
recent album raven just is bringing out
a new album
um there's a lot of bands with with
musicians who are you know quite aged
who are still
fresh putting out new new stuff but um
yeah and iron maiden's last two albums i
think are pretty damn good yeah yeah
um and we should probably do something
about that like classic
metal bands that have continued on
into um the present
doing doing interesting work and they're
not just sort of like riding the
right uh what would you call it the uh
unfolding train yeah exactly yeah yeah
well this is this has been a great
conversation um we you know we'd like to
thank all of our
participants for for your input
um i'll let scott have the last word
about the
the video
scene um and then we'll we'll call it a
day
well yeah i guess one quick thing is um
in the notes that we traded back and
forth you ask a question that we didn't
get to did video kill the radio star
yeah i think we'll save that for next
time right we'll save that for next time
but i have to say
talking about we what we talked about i
would have to say no because there we we
just said that there was video and
concert appearance everybody says
christopher cross right he he was no
more but that guy was making tons of
money and he was on talk shows in the in
you know the late 70s early 80s and
that that's a discussion for another
time but i did just want to throw that
one in there that
it goes along with what we've been
talking about today that it did exist
before it just wasn't mtv era exactly
so rich conversation thanks again scott
for for coming on i always love those
conversations that we get to have thanks
to everybody else
and we'll see you next time
you